[AUDIO LOGO]
ROMIN IRANI: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to a new
episode of "Architecting
with Google Cloud."
I'm Roman Irani.
I work as a developer
advocate at Google Cloud.
Podcasts have seen
significant growth
as a medium of entertainment
and keeping up to date
in topics of your
interests, but what
are the elements of designing
and running a leading podcast
platform with 1.5 million users,
and more importantly, tuned
to their preferences in terms
of topics and local language
content?
I'd like to welcome
Rushabh Vasa who
heads the technology platform
behind India's leading podcast
platform.
Welcome to the show,
Rushabh, can you
tell us a little bit more about
your background and your role
at Agrahyah Technologies?
RUSHABH VASA: Thank you.
Hi, I'm Rushabh Vasa,
co-founder and CTO
of Agrahyah and Aawaz.com.
Aawaz is India's leading podcast
platform in Indian languages.
We are available
in five languages
and distributed
through 14 endpoints.
We generate more than 9
million streams every month
with more than 1.5 million
users using our services
through different endpoints.
ROMIN IRANI: Thanks for
sharing your details, Rushabh.
How did you first
think about this idea
and what led you to create this?
RUSHABH VASA: Sure.
So as podcasting was
growing in India,
we identified the need for
Indigenous audio streaming
platform for Indian
listeners and creators.
That's when the idea
of podcast was born.
We wanted to build a
cutting-edge technology-backed
streaming platform
for Indian users.
We started working on
it in 2018 and launched
Aawaz.com in January 2019.
ROMIN IRANI: Interesting.
And given that there's
so much diversity
in the number of users,
their language preferences,
and platform choices,
could you tell us
a bit more about the process
that you went through
to solve this problem?
RUSHABH VASA: So when we
started building the platform,
we realized Indian
users are different.
So our focus was always on
providing a seamless and better
streaming experience
whenever and wherever they
are streaming from.
Hence we focused on
building a robust platform
and distribution.
Truly, our users can
listen to our podcast.
We have 14 different endpoints
like website, Android app, iOS,
KaiOS, Indus OS, Jio Set-top
Box, Fire TV, Amazon Alexa,
Ola Play, and so on.
We also recently
launched our app
on Visteon's In-Car
Infotainment System
so people can listen to their
favorite podcast while driving.
ROMIN IRANI: That's quite
a wide variety of platforms
on which you are available.
And particularly, right,
what I find interesting
is you mentioned that
Indian users are different.
Could you share a few
points around that?
RUSHABH VASA: Sure.
So Indian users and
content consumption habits
are different.
For example, most of our
listeners come from tier two
and tier three cities of India.
And since internet
connectivity was an issue,
we had to make sure
the listeners have
seamless streaming
experience while listening
to their favorite podcasts
even in low bandwidth.
Also we found a few interesting
things, like a lot of users
have preference to download
the podcast and listen offline.
When we tried to
figure out the reason,
we came to know that users are
conscious and conservative when
it comes to using data.
Since podcasts are new
in India, discovery
is also a big challenge.
That's where we use the data
and build a basic recommendation
mechanism where users get a
personalized notification based
on their historic
listening patterns
and also make it
culturally relevant,
like sending notifications for
Hanuman Chalisa on Saturday
morning.
ROMIN IRANI: Fantastic.
You've talked about building
a robust and better streaming
experience for your
users, plus there's
support for multiple languages.
It's going to be very
interesting for us to learn now
how you built this
on Google Cloud.
So could you guide us through
a dive into a user's journey,
or specifically,
what happens when
a user wants to listen
to a particular podcast
and they click Play?
RUSHABH VASA: Yes.
As I said, our distribution
is our strength.
It requires a
seamless experience
for our listeners to stream
their favorite podcasts
on all platforms.
That's where our robust
architecture on Google Cloud
platform helps us achieve
this performance at scale.
So just to explain you
about the architecture,
whenever a user clicks on a
play button or sends a request.
Let's say they've opened
a website Aawaz.com.
That goes to Cloud DNS where
we resolve that domain name
and then through a Cloud Run,
we load a front-end website
for the user.
And then whenever a
user clicks or selects
any particular
episode that he wants
to listen to on a
podcast, that again
requests come through
a load balancer
because there are millions
of streams coming every day.
So through load
balancer it goes,
the request goes back
to the Compute Engine
and that's where the backend
APIs are managed through that.
Our Cloud Storage gives them the
right episode file, the image,
and thumbnails.
Then again, that information
sent back to the user.
That's where the user gets
to listen to his podcast.
Let's say if the request
comes from the backend API,
then again the Cloud
handles the partner's API
that we have built and those
APIs are then again processed
to our Compute Engine and then
the same process is followed
and users get to
listen to the podcast.
With the help of
this architecture
it was possible to scale
from 10,000 streams on Day 1
to more than 90 million
streams monthly.
ROMIN IRANI: Interesting.
Thank you for taking us
through that user journey
and what happens from an
architecture point of view.
Now, looking at
the scale, and I'm
sure this is just
the start in terms
of the popularity
of your services,
so I'm sure that the journey
that you've reached till now
had its fair share
of ups and downs.
Could you highlight
any challenges
that you faced as you
went through your journey
from a technology point of view?
RUSHABH VASA: Yes.
There have been many
challenges, as you said rightly,
but one major challenge became
when we started growing.
We reached from 2 million
monthly streams to 6 million
streams in just four months
and that traffic was coming
from multiple end points.
So it was difficult for us to
manage that kind of traffic
because we were not
prepared for it.
And that's where we used load
balancers and other techniques
to solve this problem.
ROMIN IRANI: Great.
Now, you specifically mentioned
certain Google Cloud Services
which have helped
you in your journey.
So any examples you would
like to dive further
into and highlight
that have helped
you to achieve the scale?
RUSHABH VASA: Yes, like I said,
we have used many services,
but I would specifically like
to talk about the Google's
BigQuery and Data
Studio because that
has been a great help for us.
Because as we started
growing, our content strategy
is solely dependent
on our analytics.
We analyze and study
what type of podcasts
users are listening to.
We capture a lot
of detail analytics
of the users like what
they are doing on our apps,
like what kind of genres
users are listening to,
the completion rates of
their favorite podcasts,
the comments that they
are putting up there,
the demographic and
content popularity,
language-wise podcast streamed.
And that helps us create a user
persona and many other things.
This data helps us
take informed decision
on our content
strategy, which led us
to users spending more
time and listening
to the podcast on average.
Also we shared the
Data Studio dashboard
with our clients
and sponsors to look
at the real-time data on how
their podcasts are performing
on Aawaz.com.
ROMIN IRANI: It's
great to see how you've
captured user
preferences, giving them
personalized recommendations.
Could you maybe share or
dive into the architecture
behind this solution too?
RUSHABH VASA: Yes.
So whenever a user performs
any action on our website
or on mobile app, that action
is captured in terms of events
and we have built
our analytics logic
which helps us
capture that event
and process it on our system.
So whenever that data is
captured on local device,
we pass that data from the
local device to the Cloud
using a CSV.
That CSV is then transferred to
Cloud Storage where we extract
the data from the CSV and
store it in the Cloud Storage
for a backup.
From there it goes to the
BigQuery and BigQuery,
we again then process that data
and query the required results
that we want.
And then that results
are stored on a dashboard
that we have built for our
clients using the Data Studio.
Also we have used a
personalized dashboard
which helps us get
more deeper insights
about the user listening
patterns and the user data.
ROMIN IRANI: Thank you,
Rushabh for sharing what
happens behind the scenes here.
Now, what can we expect
to see from Agrahyah
in the future given its
popularity and ideas that you
may have for future
features for your platform?
RUSHABH VASA: As a
platform, we always want
to innovate and provide
better streaming experience
to our listeners.
We recently launched a
podcast in Dolby Atmos
where it gives user an
immersive audio experience.
We also introduced
Aawaz Live where
listeners can
interact with the host
in a live audio environment.
With the help of
data, we are building
programmatic audio
advertising solution
which will help
clients reach out
to the right audience on Aawaz.
ROMIN IRANI: Well, we
can't wait to try out
some of those features
that are coming out.
Rushabh, thank you so much
for joining us on our show.
Where can viewers
go and learn more
about Agrahyah Technologies?
RUSHABH VASA: Thank you, Romin,
and thanks to the entire team
at Google for inviting
me for this show.
It was really great
to interact with you.
To know more about us,
you can visit our website
Aawaz.com or Agrahyah.com.
Or follow us on
LinkedIn and Twitter.
ROMIN IRANI: With that, we
come to the end of this episode
where we saw how Agrahyah
Technologies used content,
personalized recommendations,
and local language support
to build out India's leading
podcast platform, Aawaz.com
on Google Cloud.
If you liked the
content, please share
and subscribe to our channel
where we continue to bring you
awesome tech stories.
Till the next episode,
thanks for watching.
[GENTLE MUSIC]